coïncidence des emplois du temps une
rencontre assez inattendue celle de deux
hommes qui a priori n'ont pas beaucoup
de points communs ils ont fait
connaissance aujourd'hui dans une
banlieue très pauvre de londres
l'anglais est tombé sous le charme du
français bernard lebrun pas facile
d'interviewer le prince lorsqu'ils
croisent à londres au lendemain de
versailles la télévision française et
que sur moi
suspicieuse n'est ce pas son altesse
royale a tort ils nous prêtent
visiblement des intentions qu'à aucun
moment nous nous aurions avoir enfin
presque
exceet diana c'est bien la rencontre la
toute première entre ces deux sommes
totalement opposés que nous sommes venus
filmer l'abbé pierre 82 ans âge d'entre
les sages et du prince de galles 46 ans
en instance de divorce et de passer à
côté de son destin qu'avait-il donc à se
dire qu'il durera si longtemps une
confession non un instant d'émotion
entre le plus populaire des français est
le plus célèbre des anglais de diva
chacune en leur genre des sondages de
popularité
un casting rêvée pour tous les
rédacteurs en chef de france et de
navarre
car l'oeuvre de l'abbé pierre n'est pas
bien connue en angleterre
pas encore il n'y a que deux ans que
s'est ouvert à cambridge
le premier centre emmaüs greenwich et le
troisième essai membres le dise il y a
des dizaines de demandes de création
l'objectif faire des homeless les sans
abri autant de compagnons de
chiffonniers la communauté d'emmaüs
implanté dans 42 pays et l'une de ces
multinationales de la misère on
travaille pour gagner de quoi manger
mais deux
on travaille plus que ce qui ne suffit
pour pouvoir nous qui étions humiliés
kényan en marge de la famille était de
venir donateurs donner aux autres le
prince charles lui même ne semble pas
avoir d'autres solutions dans ses voeux
d'espoir à l'adresse de la bdd avait
payé j'espère sincèrement que l'abbé
pierre reviendra très bientôt et qui
pourra inaugurer l'ouverture de la 100è
communauté emmaüs
j'attends cet instant avec impatience
applaudissements dérisoire pour un
incroyable espoirs difficile de quitter
péniche pourtant sans recueillir
l'impression de la baie après cette
première rencontre
qui aurait ainsi touché
convivial il y avait là fraudeurs n est
pas quelqu un de ses plus fidèles
il y à deux reprises il fait les
cafetiers
face à ces deux noirs jenny tx méridien
horaires universel greenwich meridian de
l'exclusion et de la misère qui
aujourd'hui battait au même rythme à
paris comme à londres avec espoir